you know even though it's cold this is
all about thermal pressures we evolved
with thermal pressures since the
beginning now we have something called a
thermostat AC right or a heater to
mitigate that you know comfort's not
good for the organism but we found a way
to make it comfortable yeah all the time
so when it's 160 degrees like you know
if you've never been exposed to 160
degrees and and you probably know a
little bit about extreme vasodilation
and vasoconstriction this is what our
blood vessels do and they need to go for
this kind of exercise but so few people
do this and it's accessible to everybody
right so if it's hot as [ __ ] get outside
you know and don't just do it once you
know if it's really cold get outside
when we're it sounds funny to say this
but we were when we were in New York
this morning
um I'm thinking okay how am I going to
get cold today and you could take a cold
shower in New York yeah you can yeah you
can take a cold so so these are things
you take a cold shower you feel like a
million bucks man you feel so good after
that and again this is accessible to
everybody you know like if there's a
time one thing I've learned through this
you know I think is just like to really
be myself
um many times I've woken up in the
morning and I'll go outside to do good
morning primals get the Sun and the
Earth my good morning primals it's time
and and you know what sometimes I didn't
really actually feel like it was prime
time you know so I'm gonna go get cold
and here's the thing you go get cold and
you there's nothing like it you know you
feel like a million bucks you know I
can't tell you how many people I've
talked to
um that can't get out of bed that and if
they can't get out of bed they can't get
out of their house like go start with a
cold shower tell me how you feel email
me right after the cold shower most of
the time oh couldn't do it yeah couldn't
do it okay start with hot just get
really hot and then turn into cold for
30 seconds and then tell me how you feel
again this is accessible to everybody
huh you know these thermal pressures
confer so many massive Fitness benefits
and Longevity benefits accessible to
everybody no one's going to financially
gain you know from this well maybe
people are selling cold plunges today
I'm not one of them yeah you know and
also saunas but we have these natural
thermal pressures that are available to
everybody you know so um I'm glad that
you guys brought this up because I
wanted to be able to plug that ancestral
tenant awesome but by the way just you
said wake up get some sun what time do
you wake up what time are you what's
your morning routine what's time you get
in the sun like just real quick I want
to know just like do you say like good
morning uh caveman like whatever your
little children was pretty much walk us
through that would you yeah so uh I get
out of bed just before the sun comes up
you know the the sun is about get that
that's I don't even know what time that
usually is so there's probably six five
fifty six okay but it depends you know
what time of the year it is so it's like
okay if the sun's getting up so am I and
then the first thing I do is I start to
I get my phone and I go outside and I
record it every morning good morning
primals it's prime time to start the day
here's my win from the previous day I'm
sharing my win you better share your win
back this is how we create the winning
mindset the winning ecosystem if you
have any negative nancies you tell them
to hold we're sharing wins right now and
now it's prime time to to stack the sun
on the earth get the Sun On You Through
The Eyes on the face on the skin this is
going to set your bio circadian rhythm
so your body and brain know when to be
alert in awake versus sleepy and
sleeping get your bare feet connected
anchored rounded into the Earth and you
don't have to do it for 20 30 minutes
right two minutes is better than none
exactly five minutes is better than two
just some connection to the Earth and
then I go piss on my favorite tree
[ __ ] a toilet toilet toilet and then I
get into the gym you know and that's my
by what time are you in the gym uh it's
usually between seven thirty so that's
your morning you're doing Primal stuff
you're walking in the sand you're you
know he's a man's man dude by the way
when you go piss on this tree because
this tree now one of these Yosemite
types
by the way your neighbors you have
neighbors that see you there there's
Brian again pissing on that tree just we
love talking about acreage yeah so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks Pride toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]